this is probably like one of the most
high-res character models out there just
because it's so big
ooh she looks bad there I love it this
is exactly why we have the show
the whole pipeline for something so
intense like this is just it's
overwhelming to me to consider the
Journey of a Thousand Miles begins with
a single step Padawan
hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artists react
we have a very very special guest today
we have Tim Miller on the couch with us
thank you so much for joining us I think
he wins the enthusiasm contest
yes he brought the 12 year old boy
energy to this process in a way that you
did not what can I say I'm just a mature
guy
younger brother yeah Tim you founded
this tiny little Indie studio called
blur you also did this little like
startup movie called Deadpool you did
like a Terminator thing like small stuff
right you forgot love death and robots
oh my god dude you're totally right I've
watched season one probably like three
full times and Seasons two and three
I've only watched once I'm afraid to say
that's all right that's right season two
doesn't get the love it deserves they're
all my children so I love them all but
season two just didn't get the love I
don't know why Tim's been very much a
part of my CG artist life since I got
into 3ds Max with version R3 I watched
all your shorts all the animations you
guys did I was constantly trying to
scrutinize and figure out how you were
getting Global illumination and ambient
occlusion good shaders and all that kind
of stuff because none of that existed
back when I got into it and cheating
that's the answer is all cheating during
the 2000s my favorite videos were the
video game cinematics like trailers and
whatnot like World of Warcraft Halo what
else was there is like freaking DC stuff
is all my favorite stuff DC Universe was
the job that got me Deadpool was it
really yep
it's really interesting that you ended
up in this realm of game cinematics
because it's a brand new medium right it
was basically invented in the 90s and
like has grown to become this thing
where it's like it's not quite movies
and it's not quite video games video
game cinematics and it sits in the
middle there but it still has characters
and storytelling and Direction but you
were at the start of that I cannot wait
to hear your stories we looked at some
old cinematics for another reason the
other day I've forgotten whole chunks of
my life
that I I watched this Hellgate cinematic
that at the time was I relived it while
I was watching it and it was just
traumatic it was so huge it was it was
like we worked on it never and I've
forgotten all about I don't even think
about it anymore and it was so important
at the time
it was like the software choice for
stuff like this this is all Max Max in
digital Fusion for compositing and
zbrush didn't exist so it was just
modeled traditionally this was one of
the first games where we could really
kind of nobody was going to go hey wait
a second that's too violent or that's
too bloody
oh that's not a good shot that face the
face is not good what stands out to you
about this yeah oh the nose is too
pinched and the forehead is too wide and
I don't know it just looks very
aggressive it looks super CG like ooh
she looks bad there there's like no
specular on the skin look at it it looks
it looks like she's made out of chalk or
something
she's very powdered up no I love it
I love it this is exactly why we have
the show
shed would say the same thing but at the
time we were like oh my God she's
amazing
oh by the way hold on that's my face on
top of that right there yeah really
that's my face they scanned which was a
little resemblances uncanny if you saw
it on a turntable you'd you'd notice it
right away they used a scan of me
because they thought it was funny I
think I'm gonna go with it was a sign of
respect at what point did you consider
yourselves like a professional Animation
Studio I'm not sure I do yet all right
okay then it just it never feels like a
job I mean I can honestly say even at
the worst of times there's never been a
day where I was like man I just don't
want to go in today and because of that
it doesn't feel like a job you know I
guess when I would say it feels like
that is especially in the beginning
there probably wasn't a year that didn't
have at least one or two sphincter
tightening weeks where it's like if this
job doesn't come in we're gonna have to
lay people off I didn't know it at the
time but we were bidding on Dante's
Inferno and I thought okay well if we
get this we're okay the orphanage had
been awarded the job but they filed for
bankruptcy and had to go out of business
oh wow and so so we got the job by
default but I didn't know that at the
time oh wow myself if that piece of luck
hadn't happened I don't know maybe some
other one would have or maybe I would
have had to finally face that crowd of
people and say sorry
I'm a big fan of smoke simulations and
there's been a lot so far here
can deny me my rights
hey look there's lots of tongue in there
the cheapest but most usable trick in
the book to make the shots look rich is
a little bit of smoke Compton with some
Sparks
it's chicken Sparks it just gives it it
just gives it all this depth like well
there's a good example of without
without the depth and it feels flat I
wasn't a good one but I enjoyed the
composite process quite quite a lot I
enjoy composing it too it's like you're
actually finishing everything it's the
last stage you put the final touches
it's like putting the icing on a cake I
wasn't very good at it in fact my quick
name was cheese filter because digital
Fusion has this filter where it'll put
the Little five-pointed Star on the
Highlight okay
I love that filter and I would put it on
everything and and the guys were like
dude why do you put that cheesy filter
see now back in the old days you did
every part when I did shots on Johnny
and monic I did everything so even
touching Upon A lot of these awesome
films that you've worked on but we have
not touched upon who I think is one of
your most significant contributions to
the world of Animation which is love
death and robots which I might also add
has been traditionally our most
requested thing to look at through the
entirety of our show is it because
people want you to bag on it no the way
you bagged them the way you bagged on
Sonic like like a bunch of like a bunch
of YouTubers just looking for YouTube
spineless
Daddy
[Laughter]
that's kind of relationship you have to
have with the internet you know yeah you
don't get that much from me I'm glad you
said that love death and robots is
probably the most important thing I feel
that I've been a part of because it
fully engages blur which I'm very
passionate about and not like I said I
was an animator first and foremost so
you know my love is animation
the vast proportions of his features I
really like the drown challenge too
because it reminded me a lot of like the
calicot winner like the really fancy
Illustrated children's books that you
get from the library once oh yeah like
Polar Express those yeah yeah exactly
like this very much feels like one of
those books brought to life like kind of
surreal a little sad perhaps a touch
dark for kids but a great excuse to make
cool paintings in a book I imagine there
had to have been a ton of work going
into all like the micro details of
everything about this this is probably
like one of the most high-res character
models out there just because it's so
big
yeah it's so nice the detail around all
of I mean the pores aren't stretching
because he's dead but like the floors
are there sorry that was a bit of an
inside joke
and it's like what is a hair or a nipple
hair look like when it's scaled up you
know yeah when it's as thick as a corn
stalk
and water on the beach which you know
you couldn't even do a few years ago
what is the hardest thing right now to
do in CG I still think it's people's
faces okay sorry that's too easy of an
answer yeah
not counting people's faces a few years
ago I would have said water but I think
they've pretty well conquered that I
don't know I don't think anything's
Beyond CG artists these days yeah that's
kind of sad now that now that you
pointed out is that sad
well maybe a little because it kind of
removes some sort of like
the challenge the challenge of it there
was nothing morbid about this because
for all intents the giant was still
alive for me when I first started
watching this at points I was like I'm
pretty sure this was filmed like it
looks like real Landscapes and whatnot
we were gonna shoot it you're gonna
shoot this for me we're gonna shoot it
yeah we had multiple plans that started
with going over to the UK to shoot it
and then the last ones we were making
were go to New Zealand and Sean Haworth
was a production designer on Terminator
and Sean and I sort of figured out we
were going to build parts for the actors
to walk on and all kinds of stuff okay
so we had a whole plan and it was I was
actually looking really forward to
shooting it and then we couldn't and
then we had to do the mo Catman pandemic
happen oh and you know the mocap digic
our friends who did one of my favorite
ldr episodes secret War their mocap
stage was still working so I directed
mocap via an iPad in Hungary which was
um not easy but but I imagine doable
some weeks elapsed before my next
Journey to the beach and by then any
human likeness held by the giant had
vanished it's a little weird when you
try and tell so what happens in your
story well this giant washes up on the
beach over a period of weeks he rots and
then people forget he was over there
what's it mean what do you want it to
mean I
I'm thinking like it's a meditation on
life and I couldn't even tell you why it
stuck with me but I read it my dad had
this book chronopolis and Other Stories
in his library and I found it and I read
the story and I always remembered it my
wife said the other day she's like
you're always going on about story like
story is so important she's like why
don't you do a just a straight up action
piece for the next love death and robots
and I had to think about it for a second
and then I thought I've done so much
action in my career that I think it just
wasn't a challenge anymore I enjoy it
but it wasn't a challenge whereas story
is hard swarm is a good example welcome
Dr Mick
honor to meet you Bruce Sterling's
original story is really rich and I
think why I love it is because there's a
lot of philosophical conversations about
technology and hubris and humanity and
what we believe and I tried to put all
that stuff in the script and then I just
ended up cutting it out cutting it out
cutting it out because it just doesn't
work in this form interesting you just
don't want to sit there and have people
monologue like I'm doing now in this
interview but that's like that was going
to be boring and you're gonna and you're
going to edit the [ __ ] out of me I I
have talked for four hours ladies and
gentlemen when you see it it's going to
be 20 minutes no it's going to be two
episodes of 20 minutes I'm still boring
just
swarm is a near perfect organic system
the resource like this we can bring
order to the chaos of human expansion
this episode I loved the Sci-Fi concept
of you have like this alien race that
has existed for millions of years and
the hubris of humans being like Oh we
can use this yeah and then be like nah
there's a reason we've been around for a
million years you just don't realize it
yet
but you may address me as
War it was such a good moment in the
story and a little bit about Bruce
Sterling he wrote this one and I tried
to get swarm in season one Bruce
wouldn't respond to me I think some
authors feel like you know I wrote the
story and that's really what I wanted to
do I don't care about this stuff and to
be fair most of the time people would
pick it up and I can't say that I didn't
did his story was not much better than
my short because it is and which is in
our books we published all the original
short stories from cohesion press and
you can get it on Amazon Netflix doesn't
make any money on it we don't make any
money on it all the money goes to the
authors and Publishers okay because I
want people to read the original stories
that inspired them and in the cases of
like hibaro where there was no original
story there's only like three or four of
those we have a scripts so you start
with the script and you have all like
these elements you got to go through and
I guess concept art what everything
looks like then there's the whole
process of converting that into actual
assets that can be used the whole
pipeline for something so intense like
this is just it's overwhelming to me to
consider the Journey of a Thousand Miles
begins with a single step Padawan
you're right it is overwhelming when you
look at it this way but I don't consider
myself a writer but I did the adaption
to this and when I do that for these I
just take the original pros and I just
put it and put it in final draft and
script format and then I just you know
start cutting it down there's
differences between scripts and pros and
you know turn all the inner monologue
into active dialogue or change the scene
and get an idea across visually and then
you get like this moment was not in the
novel but it's one of my favorite
moments where I'm like this is the time
when she's going to see the glory of
what this thing is in the Swarm so blur
obviously did several episodes in these
three seasons so far but so did a ton of
other Studios why not do everything
through blur why give the creative
freedom entirely to a bunch of other
Studios to make these episodes happen
funny you should ask there's a lot of
reasons for that the first one is you
know I used to have this dream of
building an animation Empire I no longer
have that dream I'm quite happy with the
size that blur is which is you know
about 105 110 staff but I don't want to
manage a company of four or five hundred
people you get to a point where it's
just cogs the machine and I don't like
that plus I think the variety is the key
for this show and it's great to get
other artistic perspectives there's a
lot of amazing Studios all around the
world most of them are competitors in
the game cinematic market so we know
them and they're friends and they're
very passionate about doing this kind of
thing and so why not enlist them in the
effort and it worked out really well
originally love death robots I thought
would be a little more Kumbaya a little
like artists would come in we had
animators come in and Pitch US stories
and it worked out well with Alberto but
that was about it really okay it's just
much better if I find the stories and we
develop them because then development is
hard at least if you start with a short
story you know it yeah yeah and you can
build on it
this one's great this Robert Valley did
Zima blue and Ice Rich Larson wrote ice
is a great story I'll change the ending
it was a little depressing the brothers
didn't hated each other at the end I'm
like I can't have that I like heroic
stories generally speaking even if
they're dystopic I feel like it's too
easy to end a story on a negative note
because like you always need your drama
like it takes you there but it's easy to
just be like okay and that drama's
unresolved and things are bad at the end
it's like no yeah let's get somewhere
that's the thing with shorts like I like
those little Slice of Life things where
you don't have to tie everything up in a
knot but I think you get a feeling for
when you do
you remember that movie The Net with
Sandra Bullock at the beginning of that
movie The Columbia logo comes up and a
cursor comes across and it clicks on the
Columbia woman and she fuzzes out and it
goes into some you know hacking looking
titles and I use some you know Kai's
power tools to plug in to to do it but
it worked
oh I remember these this is terrifying
shots I did 11 shots all of my shots are
the cyber space shots what's your
favorite stories and don't make them be
ones I directed Zima blue is one of my
favorites Sony's Edge was a fun one I
liked a lot swarm was one of my
favorites
that was no like ask my wife she she
knows that I liked that one foreign
[Music]
at the moment so if you're missing out
by not subscribing maybe consider not
missing out by subscribing so we got
this big old YouTube Studio but it
started with me and Sam wanting to make
videos and now we have like 20 people
working here you have a big old studio
and I got like 100 people working for
you how do you hold on to still getting
to be a filmmaker or Storyteller or
animator while also running a company
you have to have good people that are as
passionate about the other aspects of
the business as you are so there's the
people management skill which you have
to keep people happy and then there's
the business I'm lucky that I don't give
about money but the job is primarily
keeping your employees happy and and
paid and then you get to do that cool
well I'm definitely surrounded by some
of the best people I could ever hope to
be surrounded by here so I guess I'm on
the right track I also have learned that
85 of the people will appreciate what
you do and the way you try and run the
company the other 15 will never
appreciate it I feel like I've always
made the best decision for everybody
which doesn't mean it's the best
decision for everybody but I always try
and do it for the greater good for
whatever we do that's really great
advice thank you for sharing so I know
we've now finally Looked at Love death
and robots a lot so all of you leaving
those comments probably don't know what
to do with your lives anymore well guess
what you can still leave comments I mean
yeah it just takes a little bit of time
to get around to some of these things
but you know we do read the comments to
get ideas for what to look at so your
comments matter thank you Tim thank you
so much for joining us that was my
pleasure I enjoy people that enjoyed the
work that I enjoy but in honesty it's
been a big moment for me to actually be
able to meet you and talk to you serious
I'm uncomfortable with that come on I
mean two other people that like learn
3ds Max who were like animation
you know what one of the nicest things
that you'll appreciate this but when
love death and robots came out Gary OS
called me who invented 3D Studio for
those of you don't know and Gary's like
I'm so proud
that's awesome that was very meaningful
to me well that wraps up just a casual
Tuesday for us here I guess it's
Thursday
what day it is it's like whatever when
you love your work time seems to stop
thanks for watching Everybody I'll see
you in the next one